oui Myriam ma chérie on a on a ah les
pélissars encore dans la sauce alors les
pays ça vous savez de famille nombreuse
ils sont encore dans la sauce après un
reportage sur leur vie encore oui alors
Jeremstar a fait une nouvelle vidéo avec
Amandine et Alexandre pélissa et dans
cette vidéo Amandine qui est enceinte
jusqu'au cou a raconté qu'elle
continuait les vidéos porno et puis
surtout elle a eu des propos un peu
choquants pour les internautes et
qu'elle a dit que j'habite c'est son
mari était était grave sous l'eau parce
que elle était en manque tout le temps
et du coup elle a eu des phrases pas
très très sympa comme j'habite et
vidanger il n'en peux plus voilà ce
genre de phrase regardez l'extrait
c'est très sympa en tout cas Myriam
bravo
on va toujours autant l'air ah oui
toujours
faire
ça te paye pas ton bébé non moi ça me
fait pas rire ça me fait plutôt de la
peine pour ça te rappelle des bons
souvenirs
ça va être son dernier moi je pense
qu'elle aurait pu faire une pause sur
les réseaux sociaux ça va être pas mal
pour les autres enfants pour elle enfin
voilà ça me fait un peu de peine mais
alors ce qu'on apprend aussi dans cette
vidéo c'est que elle risque la prison
parce que là elle a fait appel d'une
condamnation où elle avait pris six mois
de sursis en 2016 pour avoir volé de la
nourriture dans des magasins et comme
elle est récidiviste qu'elle avait été
déjà été condamné un an auparavant pour
avoir fait des chèques sans provision il
se peut qu'elle appelle elle prenne de
la de la prison en tout cas si elle
accouche avec un bracelet électronique
donc ça aussi
je vois des trucs là qui passe des mecs
ils sont ils sont tranquilles ils ont
non mais on entend des fleurs on entend
des trucs de fou ici il y a des
harceleurs ils ont été avec un couteau
chez une meuf tout ça non c'est bon
t'inquiète ça va et elle a volé de
roches elle va se retrouver avec un
bracelet électronique alors elle ajoute
qu'elle est très demandeuse depuis
qu'elle est enceinte et que son mari
comme vous l'avez dit est au bout du
rouleau j'habite
[Rires]
ça s'envoie toujours autant l'air ah oui
toujours
en ce moment
2 chaabi il est il est il est vide le
pot il en peut plus
ils ont adoré cette vidéo ils ont voulu
avoir non elle évoque aussi toutes les
critiques et surtout les signalement
anonymes qui l'ont conduit elle et ses
enfants avec interrogés par la police ça
c'est chaud regardez voilà les critiques
ou la vie des gens sans contrebalance
complet ce qui était beaucoup plus
compliqué à gérer ça a été
les conséquences on va dire nos enfants
se sont quand même retrouvés dans un
commissariat est interrogé par des
agents de police à cause de ces
Allemands anonymes des internautes des
internautes c'est un jeu pour eux
d'aller dénoncer et envoyer des organes
de commentaires toi c'est bon tu as fait
le signalement ouais attends vas-y moi
aussi je vais en faire un haut et puis
toi ouais moi c'est bon j'en ai fait un
document des cours et anonymes c'était
signalement anonyme évidemment tout est
anonyme sauf que les conséquences
directes elles sont été répercutées sur
nos enfants
c'est nos enfants quand même ça chez
flic on se retrouve au tribunal enfin
juste pour enfants
merci bon voilà donc voilà on espère ça
va s'arranger quand même pour moi je le
reçois pas de mal franchement il faut
pas la c'est c'est pas qu'on voilà ça
c'est trop là qu'on parle de bracelet
électronique assez n'importe quoi
excuse-moi franchement là on devient fou
de de son amusé d'ailleurs comme tu l'as
dit je pense même pas qu'elle est le
bracelet électronique si elle a un bras
tonique c'est que vraiment on est dans
un monde de fou quel scénariste tout en
fait c'est une façon encore une fois de
faire du buzz et de faire parler d'elle
c'est son fond de la ris qu'elle risque
quand même très attachée à ses enfants
enfin vous irez rencontrer c'est pas et
elle ok il y a les réseaux sociaux mais
ça l'a beaucoup inquiété de cette
histoire c'était pas quelque chose pour
elle de base